the 2020 presidential race officially
begins with the Iowa caucuses which are
362 days away from today so we went to
Drake University that's in Des Moines to
get reaction to the State of the Union
speech from five Iowa voters two
Democrats two Republicans and one
independent CBS this morning Saturday
co-host that's Michelle Miller is at the
State Capitol in Des Moines with more on
what they had to say Michelle good
morning to you good morning with a six
of us huddled together as you said at
Drake University last night to watch
that 82 minute long speech you know
folks here the voters they're used to
all this national attention so with the
Iowa caucus less the caucus is less than
a year away we decided to find out what
does Iowa think was this a win for the
president by a show of hands he gives
what I call a surfboard of glory speech
you come out you talk about unity then
you talk about how Great America was and
then you talk about risk and sacrifice
and so it's it's like ride the surfboard
to glory with me because that's where
we're gone if you choose to get on board
for you Nicole you're a special ed
teacher you have voted for President
Obama you voted for President Trump what
resonated in the speech for you um just
like we're where he's been where he's
bringing us he health care that was a
big one for me because I believe that
the health care system is a wreck
there were a couple of asks in this
speech there was an ask to move forward
on the wall there was an ask not to seek
revenge what did you see being played
out there no investigation that just
shocked me that he would made that ask
in that manner show of hands how many of
you believe were headed toward another
shutdown four out of five Aaron why are
you on the fence I think that the pain
of the shutdown
is something that no one really wants to
go through again as a leader I don't
think it's safe your constituents your
people in confusion when he said that he
wants the wall and in this package she
started listing out all the money that
he wants for this and that I honestly
felt that there was no room for
negotiation Aaron you're a fifth
generation farmer you have lived here in
Iowa all of your life
why are immigrants important to you
we're a country of immigrants I think
there's room to make it so that we have
a fair path for people to come to this
country we have a big need in Iowa for
labor and that's important to Iowa farms
to have reliable labor so I don't buy
that that it has to be one extreme or
the other I think there's a fair path in
between problem is that the system is
archaic to do the legal thing is not as
easy as people think but people are
fleeing because this member bodies of
children appear everyday in the streets
I have two six-year-old grandchildren
who are beautiful and and and I love
them dearly and if their life was in
danger I would do anything to save them
the last question I posed to this panel
was simply did the President's speech
make them feel better about the State of
the Union
two of the five said yes which pretty
much fell along party lines Nora hey
Michele is it cold out there just a
little bit take that scarf and bundle
off this way yeah I'll do anything for
you all Michele somebody at the tables
that looks like you grab the blanket off
the bed and put it on your neck the
initials R n OD just but you look good
out there that was a good I don't know
okay yeah I'll stop hating on my scarf
even you warm it's doing its job that's
right